[MUSIC]
Often, what we're encountering,
the pain that we're discussing,
the frustration that we have,
is actually the result of past success.
We probably have to keep in mind
Moore's Law and other laws that apply to
the improvements that have happened
in tact, so things move very quickly.
I talked about this in
a couple of context,
but Ken Schreiber is one
of the agile signatories.
He talks about three sources of
variation in software development.
So one of them is infrastructure,
it's changing all the time.
The other is requirements,
there is always new and
different things that we can do.
And the third is people,
people working individually and
people working together as teams.
And I think in this regard,
you find yourself in an organization,
you see that things are frustrating,
and I think, or
that they're not perfect, and I think
you have to take the perspective,
with this sword, right [LAUGH], with
these people, I will solve this problem.
Otherwise, it becomes like
blame focused, right?
And so, without that appreciative
inquiry, and without that
belief that your sort of colleagues in
your organization is healthy in the way
that I just described,
your options are super limited.
I can't fix the problem because
it's the attitude of my colleagues.
And so what I want you to try to do is I
want you to view the situation you're in
as maybe an inevitable
result of early successes.
And this really changes the paradigm
to one of like, okay, everything that
we did to get us here today has
been super helpful and awesome.
It also cannot be or may not be what
takes us forward to the future.
So what is that going to look like?
And then you can turn right to those
same people who created the current
awesome in your organization.
Yes, some pain came with that,
but the current awesome.
And you can work with them, through
inquiry, to find new ways forward.
[MUSIC]
So the healthiest mindset you
can have as you approach DevOps
transformation is one of inquiry and
appreciation.
So appreciation for
your environment, appreciation for
your colleagues, even an appreciation
for the problem domain.
It's very easy to see the limitations
of your system in the present moment,
so it's easy to blame.
It's much harder to look
to your colleagues,
to look to the situation as
an opportunity to create new things.
And I think that's the heart of
DevOps is being able to recognize
that there is a path forward, and
that path forward is only going to be
realized when we work together, when we
take a stance of appreciative inquiry.